hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
were back on Monster Hunter world again
and today we're gonna be discussing how
to defeat the quest sapphire star
guidance so with that like to be if you
do enjoy subscribe before new I covered
the event quests of Monster Hunter world
as well as a bunch of solo guides
including the three monsters that are in
this quest as well as tips and tricks to
basically help everyone become a better
Monster Hunter player such as my
previous videos and with that let's get
started so first you have to be a
minimum HR 100 to unlock this quest so
it might take a little bit of grinding
to do luckily there are usually event
quests that released to boost your HR
quicker so be on the lookout for those
quests and farm them repeatedly but the
quest as you fight a tempered couche
oliday aura tiara and newark agon say
just in case for a quick recap tempered
means that they do more damage and as
well since there's more than one monster
in the quest all the monsters overall
health pools are a little bit lowered
the more monsters in this quest the
lower it goes so hopefully that clears
everything up this quest isn't
necessarily hard because of the fact
that there's three of them but this
isn't a simple stroll through the park
it's still a little bit of a challenging
fight I'm not gonna go into specifics in
terms of the monsters move set because
I've already covered each of these three
monsters in a guide before so you can
click the I on the top right right now
and you'll be shown all three of the
guys for the monsters in this quest or
the placed at the end of video and
you'll be taken to all of my solo guides
and you can do it that way in these
videos we go over the monsters move set
and figure out to tell what move is
coming how to dodge it as well as the
recommended loader to use and the flight
in tips to take note of so that sounds
interesting click those but I'll go over
some tips and loadout ideas so just so
you can become a little bit more
equipped for this quest going off to
report the best place to hit push
holiday Ora is in the head unless you're
a ranged user then aim for the tail and
Coachella is mainly weak to thunder and
Dragon element burner ghonte sword users
should aim for the legs and blunt
weapons should aim for the head range
users you guys can choose a review once
a hit and for the elemental weaknesses
nerdcon say is most weakest to thunder
and Dragon as well and then lastly we
have T Ostra and you should always be
hitting him in the head of the girlís of
your weapon types to tell us the most
image and toaster is weakest to face and
water element the most so definitely use
those type of weapons although it does
say thunder is the most damaging
elemental for about half of these
monsters
I recommend dragon because of its elder
seal ability elder steel effects the
Elder Dragons moves for example in each
of the monsters elder seal against
crucial a day or prevents his windproof
armor shown on screen
elder shield against tail
to prevents his blast and fire coding
surrounding him and former Gonzaga
prevents his spikes from coming back
faster by slowing down the time it takes
to grow them and breaking them faster
any other sealed weapon will work for
this but a high elder Xu is clearly more
better than a lower elder shear weapon
so choose at your own risk next up is
the recommended load off for each
monster and for crucial a flash pods and
the Rocksteady made those should be the
number one choice because if the high
winds qu shala makes and the fact that
Rochelle is always in the air most of
the time the windproof skill can also
help but I didn't use any since it would
be lowering my damage and that would
affect my build but once again it's
entirely up to you how you want to
approach this fight for Telstra I
recommend the fireproof mantle of course
because of his fire attacks and since
he's temperature does a lot more damage
with these if you choose any other
mantle like that you want like temporal
vitality Rocksteady etc but the
fireproof mantle should definitely be
included in your loadout regardless on
top of that you should definitely bring
some cool drinks so you don't lose
unnecessary health from the lava rooms
that he's going to be in for most of the
fight and then lastly foreigner ghonte
there really isn't much that's a
necessity so it's personally up to you
he doesn't really fly in the air too
much unless he does his dive bomb
attacks you could use flash pods there
but they're not entirely that useful and
it doesn't really do some type of light
damage so you're really not really going
to be focusing on some type of proof
mantle but regardless it should be a
given but for all monsters you should
bring some type of healing and strength
items like mega Max and HM potions as
well as demon drugs and armor skin to
boost her attack and defense as well
since those are going to definitely help
you throughout the fight other than that
the quest shall be pretty easy like I
said you could wait till the end of the
video to get to click on the playlist or
click on the I on the top right right
now there's the case you're having
trouble with a specific monster in this
quest so that you could become better
equipped when you go fight this monster
but once you're finished you can head
back to a stare you could talk to the
commander will he'll congratulate you on
your success during the quest and then
give you a bunch of quest markers for
every single person basically in astera
and they all will also congratulate you
as well after that's over you're done
congratulations you've completed the
quest as always if I missed any info or
you have a strategy that works that I
didn't mention then leave it in the
comments below for your fellow hunters
to be informed with so everyone can be
caught up on this quest and know how to
defeat this thing very quickly but that
guys it's going to be the end of the day
today I'd like to be if you did enjoy a
subscriber for new I cover the weekly
event quest to tell you guys which
quests are the best as well as if it's a
type of new quest I tell you how to
defeat it like I did with them
three someone on throne taker as well as
making tips and solo guides for most of
the monsters in monster hundred world so
everybody could become a better hunter
and with that my two most recent videos
are going to be unscreened if you guys
do want to check that out when that guy
so progressed your day thank you for
watching the video peace out